dinesh d'souza gets a pardon Samantha B
uses the c-word and Team Obama we now
have a retrospective into what election
night was like for them it's kind of
great I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show so we have a lot to get to
today here on the bench Shapiro a lot of
breaking news the presidents of the
United States have been tweeting up a
storm which means that there is a lot of
stuff happening but first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over at OU max
three ultra-pure so you've heard a lot
about the grand effect of omega threes
well that is not wrong oh maybe threes
are really good for your health they
alleviate joint pain and muscle soreness
they make you feel your best
particularly post-workout they improve
your focus and your memory they boost
cardiovascular health and more well mx3
ultra-pure is the best form of omega-3
that you can find on the market it's
almost 94% pure omega-3 fatty acids it
is the it is the purest concentration on
the market they have a patented EPA to
DHA ratio of four-to-one
it is specifically engineered for
inflammation and joint pain they have
this thing you don't want you don't
believe me how peer this stuff is it is
soap here that if you put it in the
freezer it comes out clear most Omega
threes you put them in the freezer it
comes out cloudy this stuff is so pure
it comes out just as clear as when you
put it in it is the purest option okay
you're not gonna get any of the fish
burps that you think that you're gonna
get from Omega threes when you try Oh
max calm / appear let's try Oh max calm
/ appear today you get a box of mx3
ultra pure for free that's tri Oh max
calm / capiro get your free box of Oh
max 3 T ry om a XCOM / apparel again try
Oh max calm / Shapiro's try it today
comes with a 60-day money-back guarantee
so even if you don't like it you got a
money-back guarantee
are you plenty of time to try it and
you'll feel the Oh max difference again
try o max calm / appear today and get a
free box of Oh max 3 make Omega 3s part
of your diet a lot to get to hear in the
news today we begin I suppose with the
pardon of Dinesh D'Souza's so the
President of the United States announces
today that he is going to pardons and
ash D'Souza Dinesh of course has been a
guest on the program I'm friendly with
Dinesh so full disclosure on that Dinesh
is was basically railroaded back in back
during the Obama administration who's in
the middle of making an anti-obama
documentary and it was revealed that
Dinesh D'Souza had engaged in the prime
of the process of straw donations so
basically there's a woman in one
who's running for Senate and dinesh
wanted to give $20,000 to her he
couldn't he could only give $5,000 to
her so a bunch of people gave $5,000 to
Wendy long and then tonight refused to
reimburse them right he acknowledged
this in court he pled guilty in court
and he was sentenced to a certain amount
of prison time now the reason that this
isn't just a case of somebody doing
something wrong and going to jail is
because the vast majority of cases like
this end with a fine the vast majority
of cases like this do not end with
actual prosecution to the point where
somebody goes to jail and it seems a
little coincidental that dinesh d'souza
was making anti-obama documentaries just
about the time that the Obama DOJ
decided it was necessary that
dinesh d'souza go to jail what President
Trump responded today by saying that
he's going to pardon Dinesh D'Souza
Dinesh already served his time obviously
yeah here's my generalized opinion on
this I do not believe the president
should have pardon power just not Trump
any president I think it's very silly
that the Constitution has pardon power
for the president that governors have
pardon power I think it's really dumb
specifically because either you believe
the criminal justice system works or you
believe it doesn't and having one guy
who is sort of like a kadhi sitting
under a tree ruling as to whether people
ought to be spared the penalties of
their of their crimes that seems to me
rather dictatorial and menarche it
doesn't have a lot to do with the
balance of powers checks and balances of
a functioning republic I don't like the
power generally but if you're going to
use the power you have to use it very
sparingly and you ought to use the power
in this particular case I would have
thought that it would be more of a
commutation situation so there's a
difference in Parden power between
pardoning someone and commuting their
sentence if you pardoned somebody then
their crime goes away it's off the books
as though they never committed the crime
in the first place if you commute
somebody's sentence then if they were
about to serve time they no longer have
to serve time so right now there's a
serious call to give commutation to this
guy who spent 21 years in prison and
then was allowed out of prison and then
it turns out that the system got it
wrong and he's already rebuilt his life
in they're gonna send him back to prison
there's a strong call by some people
like friends might like Dana Perino that
this guy should have his sentence
commuted I agree with that
he shouldn't be pardoned because he did
commit the crime well in this particular
case Dinesh committed the crime is a
part inappropriate I'm not sure that a
pardon is appropriate I think the
commutation would have been appropriate
but he already served his time here's
where a pardon is appropriate however
Dinesh is no longer allowed to vote
Dinesh obviously can I get loans very
easily
it's hard for me to get credit cards I
think there are certain penalties that
attach to being a felon and Dinesh is a
convicted felon which means that he
couldn't have done any of those things
well Trump is wiping all of that off the
books again so I think the pardon would
have been the best solution here I think
commutation would have if the timing had
been right but do I find this to be a
wild miscarriage of justice I do not
know is it political of course it's
political right Dinesh is non president
of president Trump's side he's been a
very strong advocate for president Trump
if Dinesh D'Souza were on the Left I
don't think they'd be talking pardon
today but this is unfortunately how
pardon power works okay this has been
true for Clinton it was true of Obama
there are a lot of people who receive
Pardons and clemency specifically
because of their politics Chelsea
Manning would still be in prison if it
were not for the fact that Chelsea
Manning is a wild leftist who is
transgender Barack Obama let Chelsea
Manning out of prison specifically
because of those factors so to pretend
that the pardon power has not already
been used for innately political
purposes would be to ignore the truth of
the situation so whoa you hear the left
complaining a lot about the dinesh
pardon today I just I don't buy the
outrage I don't know that it's you know
that the greatest move in the world but
I also don't think that it's it's
unjustified and I think that the idea
that Dinesh never went to jail for this
is insane okay so meanwhile there's
there's some other news from the Trump
administration we are now in the middle
apparently of a trade war so that's
excellent
there's a lot of talk about Trump was
not going to enter into a trade war and
he decided that I guess it was
worthwhile doing so so he is he's
decided to extend tariffs to the EU on a
number of products and those products
include include steel and aluminum
according to the Guardian a full-scale
trade war between Washington and
Brussels is looming after the u.s.
announced it was imposing tariffs on
imported steel and aluminum from the
European Union the president of the
European Commission jean-claude Juncker
promised swift retaliation after the US
Commerce Secretary Wilbur Ross said EU
companies would face a 25% duty on steel
and a 10% duty on aluminum from midnight
on Thursday Europe along with Canada and
Mexico had been granted a temporary
reprieve but Ross and insufficient
progress had been made in talks with
three of America's traditional allies
and so we had we could not reduce
America's trade deficit and the waiver
was being lifted so right now we are
talking about a serious trade war that
could impact the economy it's a bad move
by President Trump the reality is that
tariffs are not good for the economy
all they are is attacks on American
citizens remember when you artificial
boost the price of products that
Americans have to buy that is a de facto
tax on American citizens they can no
longer spend their money where they
choose to spend their money plus a lot
of these companies that are going to end
up being tariffs to actually hire a lot
of people in the United States like half
of a Mercedes Benz is produced in the
United States that plans based in the
United States some of those cars luxury
items will be hit with some of these
tariffs also the president of the United
States has started a trade war with
Mexico
so now Mexico is threatening its own
tariffs against some of America's
products so a lot of American exporters
are very unhappy so today I guess Mexico
has announced that it will put its own
tariffs on products including pork
bellies grapes apples and flat steel
which sounds like some sort of weird
dish but in any case Mexico is going to
be announcing its own trade barriers
none of this is good policy the
president has benefited from a booming
economy and a lot of that is his own
doing a lot of that is Trump's
willingness to get rid of regulations a
lot of that is Trump's willingness to
lower taxes a lot of that is Trump's
willingness to allow the market to
operate freely engaging in trade wars
with some of America's biggest trade
partners is not a way to increase the
effectiveness of American business it's
just it's a counterproductive move I
know that the president has this bizarre
understanding of tariffs he believes
that trade is a zero-sum game and
there's always a winner and a loser
that is not correct and business is
going to suffer because of all of that
it's bad policy however on the other
side of the ledger
I mean we're gonna do some good from bad
form there's some bad form here are some
good from so the President signed what
he called right to try legislation so
right to try legislation has been
considered by conservatives for many
many years basically the FDA it takes
enormous quantities of time and money to
get FDA approval for a drug one of the
reason drugs are so expensive in the
United States is you have to run through
years of FDA approval process he's
before he can bring a drug to market
literally millions and millions of
dollars it takes to actually get to
market well what happens if you're a
terminally ill person and you want to
try an experimental drug well so far the
Democrats have up till now oppose the
idea that you should be allowed to try
those drugs they say the FDA has to
license every product that is used in
the United States but what about people
who are gonna die anyway why exactly
can't they try what they want I mean if
they want to try some snake oil and it
happens to work for them why shouldn't
they be given the option of doing that
that's what the right to try legislation
was so president from signed that right
to try legislation yesterday this is a
very good move
terminally ill patients the right to try
experimental life-saving treatments and
some of these treatments are so
promising but for many years patients
advocates and lawmakers have fought for
this fundamental freedom and as I said
incredibly they couldn't get it and
there were reasons a lot of it was
business a lot of it was pharmaceuticals
a lot of it was insurance a lot of it
was liability I said so you take care of
that stuff and that's what we did today
I'm proud to keep another promise to the
American people as I sign the right to
try legislation into law so there's got
no press yesterday but is a very very
good move by the ax Trump administration
again there's good and there's bad - the
Trump administration but it's foolish to
ignore the good or to ignore the bad
right we have to point out whenever any
of this stuff is happening also it is
worthwhile noting that while the press
continue to suggest that President Trump
and his administration are replete with
people who do not care about human
beings this particular piece of
legislation is obviously an attempt to
alleviate the suffering of an enormous
number of people who are who are stuck
right who have no choice when it comes
to what sort of treatment they wish to
see it's also a good argument for
libertarianism even in areas that the
FDA covers that if somebody wants to try
a drug why shouldn't the able they be
able to try that drug speaking of people
with heart inside the Trump
administration Trump actually had a
pretty good day yesterday in so far as
demonstrating you know a certain amount
of heart and compassion inside the Trump
administration there is this this was
pretty great as he was signing this
right to try legislation there's a
little kid who apparently I believe has
cystic fibrosis is that the case with
this kid I can't remember what his
condition is but this really cute little
kid and he comes to the signing ceremony
and he wants to get a hug from Trump and
it's really cute and you can see the kid
going in for a hug and Trump is busy he
doesn't really notice the kid and he
keeps going in trying to get a hug and
finally they'll see Trump notices it
and in Trump leads over he goes with
high he's very cute very very cute okay
and then that wasn't the only sign of
compassion from the Trump administration
yesterday Sarah Huckabee Sanders was
asked at at White House press conference
about school shootings and you can see
this is not the response of somebody who
doesn't care about dead kids and so many
people who are anti Trump have suggested
I think that as a kid and certainly as a
parent there is nothing that could be
more terrifying for a kid to go to
school and not feel safe so I'm sorry
that you feel that way this
administration takes it seriously and
the school safety commission that the
president convened is meeting this week
again an official meeting to discuss the
best ways forward and how we can do
every single thing within our power to
protect kids in our schools and to make
them feel safe and make their parents
feel good about dropping them off so
clearly it's the administration filled
with heartless cretins you know evil
evil people so this is not to say that
the Trump administration doesn't do
things that I find terrible at times
right or or says things that I find
gross at times I mean obviously I've
been outspoken about all of that and was
talking a little bit about the
president's response to the Rosanne
situation but this this image that is
put out by so many folks on the left
that the Trump administration is just
filled with awful terrible people who
don't care about kids is just stupid in
a second I'm going to show you the
media's response to all of this
yesterday because it truly is
astonishing first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at Zeile so there
are some things in life that make you
feel wealthy without having to spend
lots of money zeal is one of those
things you're just sitting at home and
you're thinking I could go make an
appointment at the spa for a massage but
it's gonna cost a lot of money and I
have to wait well instead of doing that
why don't you just check out Zeile Zeile
makes sure that you can get a massage on
demand go to Zeile calm Brazil's iPhone
or Android app that Zeile spelled ze e
Elcom select from top local license
pre-screened massage therapist you can
choose your favorite technique gender
preference time and location for your
massage and Zeile will send one of their
10,000 licensed massage therapists with
a massage table music and supplies to
give you a five-star massage scheduling
booking
payment fast and easy even the tip is
included 7 days a week 365 days a year
as the Oh massage therapist can be at
your door in as little as an hour
they've got privacy convenience quality
comfort I've used zeal for my wife for
my mother for my father for my sister
for my other sister we use it in the
family all the time because zeal is just
that convenient and massages are really
top-notch so to help you get started our
listeners can get 25 bucks off their
first massage right now with promo code
ben @ z ee l it spelled z ee l comm zo
comm promo code ben and right now go to
zeal comm and again you get 25 bucks off
your first in-home massage when you use
that promo code Ben it also lets them
know that we sent you so check it out
really great service at Z old comm okay
so how does the left respond to
everything happening inside the Trump
administration the only way to express
this would be to say in the most vile
and despicable possible way so instead
of dealing with the the issues with the
Trump administration instead of talking
about trade policy for example well
instead of talking about the right to
try legislation well instead of even
talking about the stuff that President
Trump says instead the left has decided
they have to out Trump Trump they have
to go lower than low so remember Hillary
Clinton said when they go low we go high
and it didn't work for her so it seems
like the the left community has decided
that when Republicans go medium they
will go as low as humanly possible case
in point the case in point over the last
24 hours is Samantha B so Samantha B as
I have said has been in a running gun
battle with Trevor Noah
and and Amy Schumer and a bunch of other
leftist comedians for most unfunny human
in the world but I think that she
clearly takes the cake err I've always
been leaning towards Samantha bee I'll
be honest with you in these sweepstakes
I've always thought that Samantha bee
was the front-runner I always thought
that she led by at least a head and it
seems that she has drawn fault like
she's drawn lengthways and now like
Secretariat in the unfunny in the
unfunny horse race
here she is yesterday going after a
vodka Trump Ivanka Trump you'll recall
had the temerity the audacity to tweet
out a picture of herself and one of her
children over the weekend because it was
Memorial Day weekend and the left said
how dare she take a picture with her kid
because there are people being separated
from their kids on the border right now
now as we discussed earlier this week
this critique makes no sense whatsoever
like no sense but that didn't stop
Samantha bee so Samantha bee
says that not only is Ivanka wrong take
that picture she is a bleep Ivanka Trump
who works at the White House chose to
post the second-most oblivious tweet
we've seen this week you know if I go
that's a beautiful photo of you and your
child but let me just say one mother to
another do something about your dad's
immigration practices you feckless so
much bravery so much class so much
decency this is how you got Trump this
is how you got Trump so in a second I'm
gonna discuss more on how the left got
Trump okay so Samantha bee obviously is
I mean I won't use the language that you
use is here but she's a very bad person
let's just say that she's a very bad
person
what Ivanka Trump taking a picture with
her baby has to do with being called a
feckless c-word is beyond me and how
amantha be keeps her job after that is
beyond me as well it seems to me that
there's certain language that is so
outside the bounds of normal discourse
that you can get fired for it like
Roseanne calling Valerie Jared and ape
it seems to me like that was a fireable
offense and it seems to me like samantha
be calling a banca Trump a feckless
c-word for no reason other than she is
in Trump's orbit and has a child is
insane it is insane
and then to go she goes on from there
obviously to suggest that that Trump
wants to have sex with his own daughter
and therefore if Ivanka wear something
tight fit that she can change him
aggression policy the rage of the left
the utter insane response of the left to
everything that Trump does is driving
more people into president Trump's arms
like Trump may not have to actually do
anything to win reelection if the left
continues to pursue this sort of
nonsense this sort of vile nonsense as
another example Mikayla Angela Davis is
a is a race commentator on C on MSNBC
and she says that in response to the
whole Roseanne thing she says all Trump
voters are racist like all of them is
actually on CNN tens of millions of
people voted for him after he showed his
cards for years where you said we are
you suggesting that they're racist or
they're yes yeah the people who vote all
the people who voted for Donald Trump
yes they may not they may not be
violently racist they main
be he's targeted he's very clear and
strategic look anti-blackness is a
strategy that has been the foundation of
part of the American process project so
it's not just that Trump is racist so
that every single person who supports
him is racist so here's what we've
learned from the left media in the last
24 hours
if vodka Trump is a feckless c-word and
we have learned that if you voted for
President Trump even if you decried some
of the things that he was saying this
makes you a racist and then they wonder
why so many people are rushing to the
arms of President Trump they're
wondering why that's happening they're
wondering why people don't respect the
media here's another example of media
malfeasance yesterday and they're
wondering why people don't take the
media seriously here's a here's one of
the CNN reporters going off on President
Trump for hosting a White House sports
and fitness day okay this is a thing
that virtually every president has held
the this White House sports and fitness
day like I remember Obama holding them
but now you're gonna hear a commentator
suggest that Trump shouldn't hold it
because he's bad the president is having
this event here at the White House today
highlighting health and fitness well
questions are being raised about the
president's own health and fitness as
you'll recall back in January the
president's doctor came out to the
briefing room and while he told
reporters he believed the president was
in good health he did say that he was 63
and 239 pounds and had set a weight loss
goal of 10 to 15 pounds over the coming
year so questions are how he was going
to do that through diet and exercise a
great deal of irony here today John is
the president is holding this event
these questions about his own weight
loss battle that are still going on in
the White House so much journalism in
Wow
I mean that's that is some serious
journalism in right here but she was
surpassed by Jim Acosta the White House
reporter over at CNN who legitimately is
an awful awful reporter I mean Jim
Acosta is a guy who believes he is Sam
Donaldson and is more like Sam the Eagle
from from the Muppets he's just not good
at this here's Jim Acosta at the White
House complaining about Sarah Huckabee
Sanders because Sarah Huckabee Sanders
made a point over the last couple of
days her point about Roseanne was you
guys were very very upset about Rosie
and you were happy for her to be fired
and maybe she should have been fired but
you don't seem quite as happy to talk
about joy Reid for example which is
obviously true CNN Jim Acosta he got
very angry that's because he has to
stand up for the reputation of the media
okay when the media starts standing for
the media and they're no longer standing
for the truth it turns out that most
consume them out Jim Acosta is the
reason most Americans are starting to
tune out the media here's here's a cost
of going after Huckabee Sanders for
saying something that is obviously true
it's a bit much I think for the White
House press secretary from the podium to
come out here and try to shame the media
and say it's somehow our fault that
Roseanne Barr put out this tweet well
that's not exactly what Huckabee Sanders
said that's bad news coverage by Jim
Acosta chin says the media's fault that
Roseanne Barr put out the tweet she said
it's the media's fault that there's this
double standard where joy Reid gets to
keep her job but Roseanne Barr loses her
job and Droid gets to keep her job
because she is on the left and Roseanne
loses her job because she was proton
which is perfectly obvious media
malfeasance media nastiness this is how
you got Trump in this how you're gonna
get more Trump so by all means continue
to do this by all means continue to
think you can out nasty President Trump
there is no one on earth who can out now
see the President of the United States
it ain't gonna work it just is not going
to work and it's also one of the reasons
why there's such joy dan Freud when it
comes to the Obama administration being
ousted because they were quietly nasty
they're quietly sliding in the knife
into so many Americans and in Trump is
just a hammer so he's just obviously out
there with Thor's hammer hitting people
in a second I want to talk a little bit
about the show I didn't read that that
obviously comes from from President
Obama having lost because there's an
amazing story in The New York Times and
a piece of audio I just have to play for
you that's incredible but first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
expressvpn so there's been a lot of
noise about social media companies that
have been letting third parties get your
user data but the truth is that internet
providers Verizon Time Warner they can
record a list of every website you visit
and they can legally give it to anyone
the Internet is basically the Wild West
and if you think people aren't mining
your data you are wrong which is why
it's time to stop trusting big
corporations with your data and instead
start protecting with expressvpn with
expressvpn you can privately and
securely surf the internet without being
tracked by anyone you can set it up on
all your devices in just a few minutes
I've set it up on my own computer you
set it up and it really it runs
seamlessly in the background of your
desktop laptop smartphone tablet it
protects me while I'm browsing streaming
downloading files or emailing
so I don't have to worry about third
party eyes on all of these stuff that I
am doing on the internet which is good
for political people like me because the
fact is that I don't want people knowing
what I'm thinking about politics until I
say it right here on the show I don't
want people digging through my emails
I don't think you want that either
that's why expressvpn is necessary using
expressvpn you can safely serve public
Wi-Fi hotspots in Starbucks so you're
just using somebody else's Wi-Fi
connection you have to worry about
Starbucks grabbing your material or if
you're at a hotel or you're in the
airport for less than seven bucks a
month you can get the same expressvpn
protection that I have and every
expressvpn plan is covered by a risk
free 30-day money-back guarantee after
you could spread in experience the
freedom and privacy and safety
expressvpn can provide you're not gonna
want to use the internet again without
it so go to expressvpn comm slash Ben
and you get your first 3 months for free
that is Express VPN expr ESS VPN comm /
Ben for 3 months for free don't put it
off do it right now and you don't have
to worry about it ever again for seven
bucks a month you're protecting your
data expressvpn comm / Ben and get your
first 3 months for free when you use
that slash Ben okay so and one of the
things that's been I think really
delicious to watch is the left had this
perception of itself as beyond sort of
beyond decent the the right was indecent
and the left was so decent and the left
was so good and the left was so kind and
they just cannot understand how
President Trump won and it's their lack
of understanding as to why President
Trump won that basically guarantees that
we'll have a serious shot at re-election
in 2020 despite his extraordinarily low
approval ratings the left doesn't
understand how he won and they don't
understand how we won because they don't
understand themselves one of the ways
that you change your own life just
speaking personally one of the ways that
you change your own life is looking at
your own flaws and then determining how
to fix those flaws so you know for me
I've had to try to get beyond my own
confirmation bias it's a difficult thing
to do to try and look at the stuff that
you want to believe and determine
whether you are right in believing those
things and for people like me you know
sometimes I get condescending I got to
work on that right there are certain
things about me as a human being that I
have to try to work on well the same
thing is true of parties parties have to
look internally and say what is it that
we have to work on the Democrats never
felt they had to work on anything
because they had made basically Trump's
case against the Democrats they'd made
against Republicans for years the case
that Trump makes against the Democrats
that they're all bad and they don't and
they like ms-13 and they're mean they're
cruel and they're nasty and they're
stupid and all this kind of stuff that's
just turnabout is fair play the
Democrats have been claiming this for
years in 2013 I wrote a book called
bullies New York Times bestseller
talking specifically about this
character tactic that has been used by
Democrats for years well
Trump won suddenly it dawned on the
Democrats or it should have done on the
Democrats but maybe they shouldn't have
been so quick about dismissing half the
American public maybe they shouldn't
have been so quick about assuming that
they were the bringers of light and
truth and that everyone who disagreed
with them was ill motivated and so
there's something delicious about
watching members of the the Obama
administration trying to cope with the
fact that Hillary Clinton lost an
election to Donald Trump which is again
that was nearly impossible miraculous
occurrence this video this audio of Ben
Rhodes the former national security
adviser to President Obama is just
delicious this is video of Ben Rhodes as
he is realizing this from a documentary
he's just realizing the president Trump
has won the presidency and it is
astonishingly glorious I came outside to
try to process all this so ought to
watch process I mean
I can't even
I can
I mean I can okay I can't I can't put it
into words I I don't know what it would
take the heart of stone not to laugh at
that it's so amazing
so ben rhoades just a garbage heap or I
think Ben Rhodes is the architect of the
Iran deal he openly bragged about lying
for the American people and there he is
I can't understand why the American
public rejected the Obama legacy why God
why and then just the the incapacity to
speak by a former novelist from his
Brooklyn apartment elevated to a
position of unprecedented power for a
guy who knows nothing about anything
it's just wonderful that's not the only
wonderful thing the fact that the
Democrats don't understand this is why
they have a serious shot at continuing
to lose it's one of the reasons why the
generic ballot gap between Republicans
and Democrats is now shrunk to near
nothingness there's a piece in The New
York Times that is that is from a that
is from a report by Peter Baker about
the emotional stages of adjusting to
president Trump's victory and it is just
wonderful here's what it says riding in
a motorcycle in Lima Peru shortly after
the 2016 election President Barack Obama
was struggling to understand Donald J
Trump's victory what if we were wrong he
asked aides riding with him in the
armored presidential limousine he had
read a column asserting the liberals had
forgotten how important identity was to
people and had promoted an empty
cosmopolitan globalism that made many
people feel left behind
maybe we push too far mr. Obama said
maybe people just want to fall back into
their tribe his aides reassured him that
he still would have wanted he'd been
able to run for another term and the
next generation had more in common with
him than with mr. Trump mr. Obama the
first black man elected president did
not seem convinced sometimes I wonder
whether I was 10 or 20 years too early
he said this is why you fail this is why
you fail I love that the level of
introspection is not about him not about
his administration it's about the evils
of the American public so the same
American public that elected him
overwhelmingly twice suddenly was evil
but had nothing with him it was them
they were the bad people he was just too
early don't you understand we were given
a gift by President Obama President
Obama he was the gift right
it was just like bleep in a box right he
just unwrapped himself and there he was
it was fantastic
President Obama came along and we should
have all just been grateful for his very
presence in front of
he was his own gift he was God's gift
which means President Obama's own gift
to the people he was his own son
presenting himself to us to die on the
cross for our sins
this was Barack Obama this was the man
and then what what I love about this so
much is that that line where he says
maybe we pushed too far maybe people
just want to fall back into their tribe
Obama was a tribalist president
President Obama had the opportunity
after his election in 2008 to bring
Americans together particularly on
issues of race he failed to do it not
only did he fail to do it he
deliberately decided not to do it and
instead to focus on tribal izing people
bipolar patterns right by trying to move
people back into their tribes so he
could then agglomerate them all together
wrap him into a ball and in this
Democratic ball that was going to roll
downhill and crush Republicans that was
his entire electoral strategy and he
still doesn't get it but it's really
delicious to watch him not getting it he
was out of touch President Obama and so
were the Democrats which is why they
lost in the weeks after mr. Trump's
election the new york times continues
mr. obama went through multiple
emotional stages according to a new book
by his longtime advisor Benjamin Rhodes
right that was the same guy you watched
there trying to struggle with the idea
that Trump had one and it was wonderful
just delicious
at times the departing president took
the long view at other points he flashed
anger he called mr. Trump a cartoon
figure who cared more about his crowd
sizes than any particular policy okay
that is true it is also true that Barack
Obama cared a lot more about his crowd
sizes than any particular policy which
is why he went around Europe immediately
after his election speaking to throngs
of people and saying nearly nothing of
substance he expressed rare self-doubt
wondering whether he had misjudged his
own influence on American history set to
be published next week by Random House
mr. Rosas memoir the world as it is by
the way the fact that that Ben Rhodes
called his memoir the world as it is is
just unbelievable
Ben Rhodes is a guy who legitimately
believed that Iran was going to moderate
if we gave them hundreds of billions of
dollars and then he's writing a book
called the world as it is but don't
worry they're not out of touch not out
of touch at all but apparently his book
offers a peek into mr. Obama's tightly
sealed inner sanctum from the
perspective of one of the few people who
saw him up close through all eight years
of his presidency few moments shook mr.
Obama more than the decision by voters
to replace him with a candidate who has
questioned his very birth I I love even
the wording is just so good it's just so
good mr. Rhodes
as mr. Obama's deputy national security
adviser through some of the most
consequential points of his presidency
including decisions to authorize the
raid that killed Osama bin Laden I love
by the way the Democrats are still
hanging their hat on that one every
president would have said go do it Jimmy
Carter would have said go do it send
more troops to Afghanistan pull most
troops out of Iraq restore diplomatic
relations with Cuba steal a nuclear
agreement with Iran intervene militarily
in Libya and refused to intervene
militarily in Syria but his book offers
a new window if only slightly cracked
open into the 44th President handling of
Russia's intervention in the 2016
election to help mr. Trump get elected
and the aftermath in handing over power
to someone determined to tear down all
he had accomplished mr. Obama alluded to
the Godfather movie mafia movie I feel
like Michael Corleone
I almost got out yes in his own mind
I'll Obama's such a tragic figure in his
own mind in his own mind he was just he
was the man he was the he was the
christ-like figure coming to save
America and then we crucified him on the
cross of Trump oh it feels good I gotta
say it did like I didn't vote for Trump
but just for that try didn't Freud sort
of wish I had I mean like that that's
and I understand listen I understand the
temptation the the we Sally left his
chair his mug right like I get it I got
the temptation and doesn't mean that
President Trump does everything right
but the fact that Barack Obama was so
deeply out of touch and that he didn't
understand the American people and that
he really believed that by polarizing
the American people he could bring us
all together again and then he felt the
impact of President Trump following him
is just great and well-deserved and
certainly well-deserved for Ben Rhodes
as well there's more to this story and I
just have to savor every moment of it
but first go over to Daley wire.com and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you get the
rest of this show live you get the rest
of Michael Klim Knowles's show live you
get the wrench to mandrel clavin's show
live you also if you get the annual
subscription gets to be part of the
mailbag which we'll be doing it tomorrow
and you get this the leftist you're as
hot or cold tumblr for 99 dollars a year
you get all of those things that is
cheaper than the monthly subscription
plus just once a you need to go over to
YouTube and iTunes to subscribe to the
show one of the reasons you need to do
that is because we have fantastic
interview shows every Sunday we have our
Sundays special and upcoming on our
Sunday special the incredible and
hilarious Joe Rogan hey I'm Joe Rogan
and tune in this Sunday to the Ben
Shapiro Sunday special the Ben Shapiro
Sunday special I don't even know what
it's called but I do enjoy talking to
Ben I love this guy
communicating with him I think he's a
brilliant person and we talked about a
lot of cool so enjoy or not it's a Jo
would be stopping by on Sunday I saw him
yesterday it was a real blast and he
will talk about Roseanne we'll get into
all the topics of the day so go
subscribe over at YouTube over at iTunes
you're really going to enjoy it I think
it's it's it's a real kick
Jozy kick in the pants he's hilarious so
check that out we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
okay so this is New York Times piece it
just continues his so long and so
glorious on election night
mr. Obama spoke by telephone with Cody
Keenan his chief speechwriter and mr.
Rhodes to figure out what he should say
mr. Rhodes asked if he should offer
reassurance to allies nope I don't think
I'm the one to tell them that the
president said because of course Obama
wouldn't actually say that our allies
would be okay
Obama by the way wasn't even friendly
with our allies now it comes to Israel
and Britain he was certainly not
friendly the next day mr. Obama focused
on shoring up his despondent staff at
one point he sent a message to mr.
Rhodes saying there are more stars in
the sky than grains of sands on the
earth really that's something that he
said to Ben Rhodes Barack Obama there
are more stars in the sky than grains of
salmon on the earth you have got to be
kidding me you've got to be kidding me
he didn't interview with glozell he did
another interview with pimp with a limp
there are pictures of him with a selfie
stick in the Oval Office there are more
stars in the sky than grains of sand and
there's what a pretentious douchebag
days later Obama seemed less sanguine he
said I don't know maybe there's what
people want I've got the economy set up
well for him no facts no consequences
they can just have a car trip Obama was
his own sort of cartoon the fact that
people couldn't find humor in Obama is
just beyond me you know yesterday we
talked about Trevor Noah
saying that Obama was not inherently
humorous are you kidding me this is a
dude who sends text messages to people
that say things like there are more
stars in the sky than grains of sand on
the earth
thanks Confucius like what in that there
is no humor in him he added we're about
to find out just how resilient our
institutions are at home and around the
world the day mr. Obama hosted mr. Trump
at the White House after the election
seemed surreal mr. Trump kept stirring
the conversation back to the size noting
that he and mr. Obama could draw big
crowds but mrs. Clinton could not mr.
Rhodes writes yes yes it's so great okay
just I said right after the election
there was one picture that really got me
right after the election was a picture
of Donald Trump visiting the White House
sitting next to Barack Obama and you
recall that Barack Obama had said on
national television that Trump would
never be president in a series of mean
tweets with Jimmy Kimmel and there is
Obama looking like he wants to die and
Trump sitting next to him giving the
Trump finger to the
camera and behind them is a bust of
Abraham Lincoln looking down it is just
amazing I love that truck because here's
the thing as I've said many times
Trump is Obama unmasked deep down
Obama's ego is Trump's ego all the talk
about crowd size Barack Obama did his
original DNC acceptance speech in 2008
on a stage with Greek columns and mist
coming off the floor in a stadium filled
with 40,000 people hey you think Obama
didn't care about his crowd sighs dude
could not stay off TV the guy wouldn't
he we wouldn't miss an all-star game you
wouldn't miss in an NCAA bracket
challenge right the guy was on TV all
the time
Trump is just the vulgar version of
Obama in terms of personality he's doing
I'm not in time in terms of policy here
the fact that Obama couldn't see that in
himself is again one of the reasons he
was so out of touch he was so out of
touch this guy who's like quoting fake
Psalms that he makes up himself
afterward mr. Obama called a few aides
to the Oval Office to ruminate on the
encounter I'm trying to play some in
American history he said he peddles Bull
mr. Rhodes answered that character has
always been part of the American story
you can see right back to some of the
characters in Huckleberry Finn maybe mr.
Obama answered that's the best we can
hope for oh so sad so sad by the way
talking with people who peddle bull
Barack Obama was in the Senate for five
minutes before he ran for president and
he gave the most BS speech at the DNC in
2004 I had heard at that time right the
whole we're not red states and boost up
more of United States but I just I love
that Trump is the bizarro he's like
bizarro Superman like Obama sees himself
as Superman and Trump is just bizarro
Superman where everything he says is
kind of backwards and he's just the the
weird version of Obama like when Obama
looks in a funhouse mirror he's gotta
see Trump and it must haunts his
nightmares and he deserves every second
of that it is so grand and it is so
great now speaking of so grand and so
great I have to tell you the story
because it is so good Joel Stein
remember Jill Stein and she was the
left's great hope she was the great hope
she was going to provide that counter to
Hillary Clinton shortly after the 2016
election according to The Daily Beast
Joel Stein raised more than 7 million
dollars from shell-shocked liberals
eager to pursue a swing state recount
nearly two years later the US Green
Party's last candidate for president is
still spending that money ongoing
litigation travel costs and staff
salaries are also likely eat up whatever
is left meaning those who donate
Steinar unlikely to receive and once
promised chance to vote on how the post
recount money would be spent north
donors been given much of a window into
how Stein is actually spending their
donations the last FEC filing from the
stein campaign was for the month of
September 2017 and the last update from
the campaign itself came on a post egg
in a post on April 20th in which it said
it was down to about a million dollars
in recount funds so did they ever
actually do any of the recounting nope
they spent it all on staff salaries and
vacations yep you guys didn't get
scammed at all the only scamster in that
race was clearly Donald Trump not Jill
Stein not Hillary Clinton man sometimes
politics is great now speaking of when
politics is not great we have to talk
about Spygate so the presidents of the
United States decided to tweet today
because today is a day ending and why so
he decided that he was going to tweet
about spy gate spy gate as you recall is
this allegation that the FBI was at the
behest of the Obama administration
looking into the looking into the Trump
campaign they were targeting the Trump
campaign because they wanted to
essentially falsify information about
collusion between President Trump and
the Russians and then use that as a club
against him the election cycle now I've
always had a few questions about this
question number one
why exactly wouldn't they release the
information if they had it question
number two the only people they targeted
inside the campaign we're people who
basically have been charged at this
point they never targeted Trump jr. they
never targeted President Trump himself
they never targeted Steve Bannon they
never targeted a bunch of people who are
top members of the Trump campaign it was
only manna fort and gates and
Papadopoulos and Carter page right all
people with serious suspicious histories
and then the third question is always
the biggest which is if all this really
happened why doesn't Trump just
declassify it but if the FBI really was
going after Trump at the behest of the
Obama administration Trump's the
president he can you classify this stuff
and any time part of the reason that I
don't buy this story is because the
president tweets things that are
sometimes just not true so here's the
thing that he tweeted that was just not
true today he said the corrupt
mainstream media is working overtime not
to mention the infiltration of people
spies into my campaign surveillance much
okay that's somewhat fair
here's the part that's not fair not that
it matters but I never fired James Comey
because of Russia the corrupt mainstream
media loves to keep pushing that
narrative but they know it is not true
he literally went on Lester Holt show on
national television on NBC and said he
fired James comb
because of Russia he then went into a
room with the ambassador to Russia from
Russia
serega kiss lyac and told him that he
fired james comey because of russia now
i don't think that he fired James coming
because come he was about to uncover
Russian collusion I think if fired James
called me because he was frustrated that
Comey was not announcing publicly that
he hadn't he didn't have the goods on
Trump about Russia but when Trump says
he didn't fire James Comey because of
Russia he literally said on national
television he literally said that on
national television the de fire James
Comey because of Russia so um no I just
I don't buy that by the way speaking of
people who don't buy it trey gowdy who
it's really funny to me you know tribal
tribalism is a hell of a drug and trey
Gowdy you will recall was considered one
of the staunchest most aggressive
Republicans in Congress he's retiring
now he was on the the I believe the
House Oversight Committee and you
remember during the Benghazi hearings
whose shellacking
the Obama administration over and over
and over who's the best prosecutor they
had on the Oversight Committee he's a
very strong Republican and he said on
Fox News that the FBI was not out to get
the quote-unquote Trump campaign in the
middle of the election cycle here's what
he had to say and the backlash was
fierce it was President Trump himself
who said number one I didn't collude
with Russia but if anyone connected with
my campaign did I want the FBI to find
that out it looks to me like the FBI was
doing what President Trump said I want
you to do find it out he's not the
target
so when Schiff and others don't make
that clear they're doing a disservice to
our fellow citizens I am I am even more
convinced that the FBI did exactly what
my fellow citizens would want them to do
when they got the information they got
and that it has nothing to do with
Donald Trump okay so what he says here
is two things one of them is that the
FBI was not investigating Donald Trump
and the other is that the FBI was not
investigating the Trump campaign now
there's a case to be made Andrew
McCarthy makes it today that the Trump
campaign was basically under
investigation I don't agree with Andrew
McCarthy's case I tend to agree with
trey Gowdy but what's happened because
trey gowdy said something you are not
allowed to say now which is that
President Trump is over blowing this
case a lot of folks have been all over
trey Gowdy Sean Hannity for example
attacked trey Gowdy on Fox News and
suggested that trey Gowdy had now been
co-opted for some reason that there's
the suggestion being made the trade
has been co-opted by the deep state or
that trey gowdy is now running
interference for democrats and for the
FBI
again trey Gowdy I believe he might be
wrong but to question his motivations
here I think is really beyond the pale
again when the evidence shows that the
FBI was directed by President Obama or
even hinted at by President Obama to
target the Trump campaign not just
people within the Trump campaign the
Trump campaign itself when we understand
why Trump hasn't Declassified the
material when we understand why the FBI
didn't release the material then I'm
happy to go with the Spygate stuff until
then I'm gonna have to withhold judgment
just as a lawyer I'm gonna have to
withhold judgment and I don't know
what's wrong with that I think
withholding judgment might be the best
thing you can do when the evidence is
not yet out okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things I like I I do enjoy reading about
you know the about human psychology and
the the natural the natural limitations
that human beings have as I said earlier
in the show I think it's a very
important thing that the I think it's a
very important thing that the be that
human beings they want to change
actually spend some time looking into
their own limitations well there's a
great book by Paul bloom psychologist I
believe it at Yale University it's
called just babies the origins of good
and evil and it basically explains that
human beings are not blank slates right
we are born with a bunch of inherent
limitations that we have to work to
overcome these limitations do include
discrimination and violence they do
include cognitive biases and it's
important for everybody to know about
these things so that you and your own
life can overcome them and so you can
educate your children better to overcome
them again the book is called just
babies the origin of good and evil it's
like it's a it's a short book and a very
easy read it's it's really fun to read
as well it'll give you some information
that puts to death the lie that the left
is told for literally generations that
human beings are infinitely malleable if
only we change our social constructs the
the idea that that boys can become girls
and girls can become boys an outgrowth
of the idea that the human brain is
intensely plastic so plastic that it has
no actual features that's not true it
never was true in human history it has
not been true and Paul bloom sort of
puts that to bed and just maybes the
origins of good and evil okay time for
some things that I hate
so yesterday as I mentioned President
Trump met Kim Kardashian in the Oval
Office and I questioned whether this was
a worthwhile thing to do because I think
that linking yourself with celebrities
is generally a waste of time and
counterproductive
I don't think celebrities generally have
important things to say on topics
outside of their purview that's not to
say they can't raise money for charity
it's not to say that they can't have
their causes but I don't know why
politicians should take the word of
celebrities as more important than
anybody else so if Trump wants to talk
prison reform and sentencing it seems to
me that he in and he thinks that Kim
Kardashian is somebody he should talk to
and seems to me that he should talk to
Kim Kardashian have Kim Kardashian
recommend an actual expert on prison
reform and sentencing have that person
come into the White House and then they
can talk about it but these whole
photo-op nonsense which is not it didn't
start with Trump obviously Obama used to
do it all the time
it is nonsense now of course what's
ironic about all of this is that
speaking of philosophical consistency a
bunch of people on the right will say no
no it's good Kim Kardashian coming in
it's great because she's trying to do
the right thing again I'm not
questioning Kim Kardashian's motives I'm
questioning the the usefulness and the
and whether it is good for the country
to have politicians doing these photo
ops with celebrities as though the
celebrities know what the hell they are
talking about in many of these cases and
I remember that there was a guy named
Donald Trump who used to be a sort of
upset about this kind of stuff right
Trump used to rip Hillary Clinton over
her associations with jay-z for example
why she filled up the arena was to get
jay-z and his language was so filthy
that it made me like the most clean-cut
human being on earth
[Applause]
okay that's a fair criticism but then
you can't go around talking about why
like Kanye should come to the White
House like just the hypocrisy is a
little bit much for me I have a
consistent stand on this I do not think
celebrities know things as a general
rule if they do know things one thing if
Trump wants to be friends with people
that's fine but the photo ops the
attempt to use celebrity as a method of
power maintenance in American politics I
hated it when Obama did I hated it when
Hillary Clinton did it I don't like it
when President Trump does it I just I'm
as consistent as can be on this and I
can't say the same about a lot of other
people on the right who just said well
you know as long as it's Trump doing it
it's totally fine but getting kind of
used to that after all these years okay
time for a quick quick Bible verse so
we've been going chapter by chapter
through the books following the five
books of Moses and this is from the
chapter 3 of the book of Joshua so
Joshua is about to invade the land and
it says early in the morning Joshua and
all the Israelite set out from she team
and went to the Jordan where they camped
before crossing over after three days
the officers went throughout the camp
giving orders to the people when you see
the Ark of the Covenant of the Lord your
God and a Levitical priests carrying it
you ought to move out from your
positions and follow it then you will
know which way to go since you have
never been this way before but keep a
distance of about two thousand cubits
between you and the Ark do not go near
it
Joshua told the people consecrate
yourselves for tomorrow the Lord will do
amazing things among you
it's that verse that I want to talk
about a little bit and the idea that you
have to consecrate yourselves because
tomorrow the Lord will do amazing things
among you if you were told today that
God was going to do something amazing
for you would you go out and consecrate
yourself or would you think well listen
it's already guaranteed right the
rewards already guaranteed so would I go
out and consecrate myself when I go out
clean myself make sure that I'm as clean
as can be
or would I just rely on the mercy of the
Lord it's my feeling that this verse has
some serious importance because the idea
is not that you're trying to buy off God
to do things for you and religion is not
about buying off God to do things for
you God is not a gumball machine what
God is is is a being that is infinitely
kind and merciful and in gratitude for
that we have to constantly be in the
process of consecrating ourselves God's
gonna do what he's going to do and I'm
not I don't believe that you earn points
with God in this life simply by doing
good things I don't think it's you do
good things and then God is nice to you
again
God is not your your candy machine but
it is your job to be grateful for the
things that God does give you including
a predictable universe in which if you
apply the rules
then good things happen to you it is our
job to consecrate ourselves and not to
worry about what God is going to do for
us because what God is going to do for
us has almost no like if people are not
consecrated themselves according to
Joshua God still would've done the great
thing it is our job to be grateful for
those great things and therefore to
spend our time making ourselves more
virtuous human beings okay we'll be back
here tomorrow with the mailbag i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018
you